Ang quantum computing ay pumasok na sa panahon ng utility
ibig sabihin, maaari na nating gamitin ang mga quantum computer para malutas ng
mga tunay na problema sa mundo kasama na ang ilan na sobrang hirap
para sa mga klasikal na computer
isang karaniwang tema sa kasalukuyang panahon
ay ang paglutas ng isang problema
sa unang pagkakataon sa isang quantum computer
at pagkatapos ay nakakahanap ang mga tao ng paraan para gawin ito sa isang klasikal na
computer ang siklong ito ng klasikal
at quantum computing na nagtutulakan sa isa't isa hanggang sa kanilang
limitasyon ay malamang na magpapatuloy
sa loob ng ilang taon may mga klase ng problema kung saan ang quantum
computing ay may mapapatunayang kalamangan
kumpara sa klasikal na computing
sa pag-unlad sa mga larangan tulad ng
pagbabawas ng mga error at bilang ng mga qubit na available
mayroon ding mga buong lugar ng aplikasyon
kung saan ang quantum computing
ay maaaring maging kapaki-pakinabang sa medyo malapit na hinaharap
isa sa mga larangang ito ay ang quantum machine learning o QML
ang quantum machine learning ay tumutukoy sa
paggamit ng quantum computing sa anumang uri ng machine
learning na proseso mayroon siyempre
maraming uri ng machine learning
dalawang uri na partikular na kawili-wili ay ang
supervised learning kung saan
sinasamahan mo ang isang algorithm gamit ang isang labeled na dataset
at unsupervised learning kung saan
ang algorithm ay gumagana mula sa mga unlabeled na sample
at sinisikap na matuto tungkol sa distribusyon
o ang function na gumagawa nito
ang isang unsupervised na algorithm ay maaaring
halimbawa matuto kung paano gumawa ng mga bagong sample
mula sa parehong distribusyon o kung paano
i-cluster ang mga sample sa mga grupo na may magkaparehong katangian
ang parehong supervised at unsupervised learning ay kadalasang kinabibilangan ng
pag-embed ng data sa mas mataas na dimensional na espasyo
at ang manipulasyon ng data sa mas mataas na dimensional na espasyo
ay dapat magpaisip sa atin ng quantum computing
hayaan akong ipaliwanag isipin ang paglutas ng problema kung
ia-classify ang isang data point mula sa plane
bilang bilog o krus batay sa labeled na training data dito
minsan ang data ay malinaw na mahahati ng isang linya
o plane sa mababang dimensyon
tulad ng ipinapakita dito at ang pag-classify ng mga data point na ito ayon sa
mga nasa itaas ng linya
at mga nasa ibaba ng linya ay
walang problema pero tingnan ang distribusyong ito
malinaw na walang makikitang linya na naghahati ng mga data point
gayunpaman para sa data na ito maaari tayong mag-isip ng ilang
mapping mula sa dalawang dimensyon patungo sa tatlong dimensyon
kung saan pagkatapos ilapat ang mapping ang ating data ay magmumukhang
ganito at malinaw na may plane na naghahati ng dalawa
klase na maaari nating gamitin
para sa classification kung mukhang simplistic ang pagtrato na ito
tama ka hindi natin basta-basta mailalagay ang mga data point na gusto nating
itaas nang walang justipikasyon
kailangang may mapping
mula sa two-D na distribusyon na epektibong naghahati
ng ating mga data point para
magamit ang mapping para i-classify ang mga bagong data point
ito ay tatalakayin pa sa aralin na nagbibigay ng machine
learning recap pero sapat na sabihin
na ang problema ay maaaring tingnan
bilang pagsubok ng maraming iba't ibang mapping sa mas mataas na dimensional na
espasyo para makita kung aling mga mapping ang nagbibigay ng pinakamahusay na
paghihiwalay ng mga data point ng iba't ibang klase
ang manipulasyon ng data sa mas mataas na dimensyon na ito
ay isa sa mga larangang maaaring
malaking epekto ng quantum computing para maunawaan kung bakit
bumalik tayo sa mga pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng klasikal
at quantum computing katulad lang
na gumagamit ang mga klasikal na computer ng mga bit ng impormasyon
gumagamit ang mga quantum computer ng mga qubit
pero para sa isang tiyak na bilang ng bits sabihin nating apat
ang isang klasikal na computer ay maaaring nasa alinman sa
dalawa sa ikaapat o labing-anim na posibleng estado
ang isang quantum computer ay maaari ring ma-access ang labing-anim na posibleng estado
pero maaari itong umiral sa superposition ng lahat ng
labing-anim na estado nang sabay-sabay
at maaaring magsagawa ng mga operasyon sa buong superposition na ito
para sa apat na qubit maaaring hindi ito mukhang
malaking bagay pero isipin ang maaaring gawin gamit ang
isang quantum computer sa dalawa sa ikadalawampung o
dalawa sa ika-isang daan at dalawampu't pito
estado nang sabay-sabay marami pang ibang pagkakaiba
sa pagitan ng klasikal at quantum computing na
lahat ay magkakaroon ng papel sa paksang ito
ang mga quantum state ay may mga kumplikadong probability amplitude
ang mga manipulasyon ng mga quantum system ay isinasagawa gamit ang
mga unitary operator at ang mga quantum computer ay napapailalim sa iba't ibang
uri ng ingay kumpara sa mga klasikal na computer
ang mga pagkakaibang ito ay lilitaw
sa buong quantum machine learning na gawain mo sa mga larangan
tulad ng data encoding feature mapping at error mitigation
sa ilang kaso ang mga pagkakaibang ito sa pagitan ng klasikal
at quantum computer ay nagbibigay-daan sa atin na mag-disenyo ng ganap na
mga bagong algorithm ngayon iyon ay isang napakaikling pangkalahatang-ideya
sa unyon ng dalawang lubhang kumplikadong larangan
pero sana ay malinaw ang dalawang bagay
ang machine learning ay madalas na naglulutas ng mga problema
sa pamamagitan ng pagmamanipula ng data sa napakataas na dimensyon
at pangalawa ang mga quantum computer ay angkop
sa pagmamanipula ng data sa mataas na dimensyon
at ginagawa ito nang kakaiba kumpara sa mga klasikal na sistema
dapat itong magbigay sa iyo ng ideya
kung bakit ang machine learning ay isang promising na larangan
para sa aplikasyon ng kapaki-pakinabang na quantum computing